Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update all that stuff that was rumored
about a new borderlands game is totally
true Borderlands the pre-sequel is
coming to xbox 360 ps3 and pc this fall
and yes that is the actual title the
game takes place between the events of
borderlands and borderlands 2 and stars
a team of four new vault hunters working
for the not yet full-blown super villain
handsome jack it takes place on
Pandora's moon that like our moon has
low gravity and zero atmosphere but
unlike our moon has a giant h shaped
space station periodically blasting
holes in it players will have to keep
track of a new oxygen meter to avoid
suffocating in the cold cold vacuum and
they'll be able to use their 02 to
perform a few new maneuvers new vehicles
and new laser weapons were also
confirmed along with cryo ammunition so
in the words of gearbox software
president randy pitchford we've got
freeze guns now if you want more details
on the character classes the weapons the
vehicles the moon jokes etc and
Borderlands the pre-sequel be sure to
check out our extensive video and
written preview right here on gamespot
com